some of today's show was filmed before
Elizabeth Warren ended her presidential
race and that's why we seem not to know
that in some of the discussions on
today's show all right
so there is huge value in fighting for
what we believe in and fighting things
out until the end until they are
actually decided particularly in
politics and so on the one hand I want
to make sure everybody who's in a state
that hasn't yet voted you should vote
and you should vote for whoever it is
that you support regardless of what the
results have been in primaries so far
there are so many delegates still
available and at the same time this is
not a show that does pie in the sky
optimism when realism doesn't coincide
with optimism in a 100% lockstep and so
what I am here to tell you today is that
we need a shift unless the path is going
to be Joe Biden as the Democratic
presidential nominee I'm not a betting
man but if you said David you've got to
make a bet my bet is Bernie Sanders is
done that would be my monetary bet
monetary bet yesterday I asked on
Twitter what do people want from
progressive media right now do you want
us to be doing the here's Bernie's path
if he can take the lead in Florida and
then somehow all the Biden voters in New
York forget to vote and you know this
type of stuff until the very end or do
you want realism and the overwhelming
results were David tell it like it is
that's why we watch that's why we listen
even if we don't like it tell it as the
facts are and of course activism can
change what the facts are on the ground
and this is not just about Joe Biden's
momentum out of South Carolina this is
not just about the Pete aimée
endorsements or the Super Tuesday
reversal giving Joe Biden more than 60
delegates as a lead over Bernie Sanders
it's not about the new polls that have
Bernie now behind Joe Biden nationally
we now have the addition of Michael
Bloomberg exiting the race and endorsing
Joe Biden tweeting yesterday quote three
months ago
I entered the race to defeat Donald
Trump today I'm leaving for the same
reason defeating Trump starts with
uniting behind the candidate with the
best shot to do it it's clear that is my
friend and a great American Joe Biden
now there is a narrative of if Warren
gets out and endorses Bernie that would
be really great for Bernie I actually
questioned that narrative
I believe it's doubtful that Warren
would endorse Bernie if she got out she
clearly sees what is going on she if she
did endorse Bernie would be completely
shut out of a possible Biden
administration to the extent anyone
believes there would be one and even if
she did endorse Bernie Sanders only a
portion of Warren's supporters are going
to go to Bernie remember that if you
look at some now admittedly stale
second-choice polls Warren's supporters
are roughly evenly divided between Joe
Biden and Bernie Sanders and remember
that that doesn't account for the
reality that a lot of people who two
months ago said I like Warren but my
second choice is Bernie if she were to
get out now even some of those Bernie
second choices don't go to Bernie
because they may want to support the
person they see as likely to win so the
point is right now
Bernie Plus Warren is still under 50%
you look at the state polls it is a very
uphill battle for Bernie Sanders so my
belief is a betting person and as an
analyst is that it's over my feelings
about Joe Biden as a centrist nominee
who himself appears to be suffering from
cognitive decline are completely
separate from the sort of factual
analysis of what's going on here and
then you know let's look at some of the
remaining states and that also paints a
pretty pretty clear picture Joe Biden is
now ahead by six in the latest Michigan
poll that's worth 125 delegates we have
no polling in Mississippi but it's a
southern state Biden will win Bernie got
only 50 percent of the black vote on
Super Tuesday Missouri we don't have
recent polling but Biden was winning by
25 in January probably an even bigger
lead at this point that's six
eight delegates Washington State is a
maybe for Bernie coming up on on Tuesday
we've had no polling from three weeks
for three weeks it was a small margin
for Bernie three weeks ago could go
either way and then March 17th which is
not this Tuesday but the following it
may be over on March 17th Biden has been
up in every poll this election cycle in
a lot of the states there Illinois maybe
would be competitive for Bernie on the
17th but then you get to Florida 219
delegates Biden was already up 22 before
the recent surge and second place there
was Bloomberg with 14 with Bloomberg out
fighting gets only half of Bloomberg
support that that could be it there and
then lastly on the 17th of March Ohio
136 delegates and Biden up in every poll
there so I'm not here to deflate people
or inflate people or make people
irrationally optimistic or pessimistic
I'm here to tell you these are the
numbers right now and the progressive
movements agenda at this point should be
vote for whoever you believe is closest
to your values in your state if your
state hasn't voted yet every delegate
counts every delegate Bernie Goetz gives
him clout and negotiating power
what could Bernie get from Joe Biden we
don't know but the strategy needs to be
evaluated candidates for elections going
forward outside of just the presidential
for the progressive movement need to be
considered the House and Senate in 2022
is going to be a big deal in terms of
who does the progressive movement run
there is one possibility here and it's
an implosion by Joe Biden I've over
night I spoke to a bunch of different
political analysts who are not
particularly well-known they're not like
you know Chris ELISA
on CNN who said Harris was bound to be
the nominee people who have been making
the right predictions all along and in
this case the prediction was the
Internet is distorting the level of
support for someone like Bernie Sanders
and it is likely that in the end Center
center left
coalesces around one person the idea is
Biden can mess this up in the same way
that you know there's a lot of people
saying when Biden and Bernie debate it
is going to be brutal for Joe Biden
we'll remember that that debate isn't
happening after until after the March 10
primaries which are likely to be very
good for Joe Biden but it is true that
the way to mess things up now is for
yourself not someone else coming in and
doing it for you
debates will not move the needle much
from this point forward unless someone
messes up and there's the potential that
Joe Biden would do that am I being too
defeatist for you tell me where I'm
wrong on the facts tell me what I should
be saying about the primary if not what
it is that I am telling you today and
that's let's now dig in a little more to
the nitty-gritty of what happened on
Super Tuesday here one of our sponsors
today is VIN Chara watches giving you
15% off your entire order when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch don't pay
thousands of dollars for a high-quality
watch that looks great
because you don't have to all of inch
Arrow's watches are made with high-end
materials masterfully built and they
look like something you'd spend a ton of
money on but ever even chera watch
ranges from about a hundred and fifty to
three hundred bucks I went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether
and silver and white really nice elegant
look it's a coronagraph style wore it to
a gala over the weekend and a lot of
people asked me where's the watch from
really really great look totally
different they also sent me the altitude
in matte black and red a much more
rugged view of what a watch can look
like really liked it as well as well as
the athletic strap it's a new year it's
a new decade it's time to re-establish
your style add something new to your
look and a high quality watch is the
perfect way to do that you can get 15%
off inch arrows entire collection when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch